you know what i just got a friend of
mine is in the casting industry you know
she's a talent manager and so she gets
these
alerts about casts castings yeah and she
sent it to me because i'm being cast for
some history channel documentary
nice
i wonder what they're talking about in
this history documentary it's something
about rebels
oh that sounds good i like that yeah i
was like wow that's i wonder who's going
to play me i'm too old to play myself i
would put myself up
you know who i love
my 30s or something oh then i got the
person
who zendaya
[Laughter]
she would do a great robin quivers on on
that channel
well i hope she gets the message that
they're looking for someone
you know what i'm thinking if not her
what do you feel about uh this sarah
shahi
what do you think come on i don't think
sarah can play me what about halle berry
halle berry halle berry i think she's
got my problem i think she's aged out of
the role you know who i loved in
batwoman
batman zoe kravitz
what about zoe kravitz i would love to
see joey kravitz now you've got to
remember i've only been played by men
before until i played myself that's
right and that was uh
dave chappelle
uh i think dave will not play me anymore
if they go to dave and say could you
reprise your robin quivers i don't think
he's gonna do it all jokes aside and i'm
being serious
beyonce
beyonce beyonce
yeah
what do you think i don't know if she'd
do it you like it because like a woman
if she she'd jump at the chance to play
you well it's not a whole i think this
is going to be little segments in this
documentary i don't know if beyonce
could be you know pulled
uh into a project like that the whole
documentary isn't about you it's he's
not playing robin quivers the movie no
well there's a lot of people probably
trying to get that part now
i thought it was hysterical i was like
what in the world is happening in my
life now they're casting somebody to
play me